[Music]
to one whoa hello everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on now
we're sitting down with Jordan miss
Callen how's it going good a little
little nervous a little excited yeah
yeah yeah thank you for coming on thanks
for inviting me this is gonna be a blast
I agree so Jordan is you you're you're
actually here for a shorter period of
time we got lucky that you're around and
that we're able to get you in
because Jordans got some cool things to
teach us you guys can tell this title of
this videos surrendered leadership what
is surrendered leadership hmm
well get to that let's talk about
Jordan's background a little bit first
so Jordan is a partner at circling
Europe so circling Europe will unpack
that as well Jordan's also an author
he's an author of a beautiful apocalypse
and he's been a coach for about six
years now so this is gonna be good let's
well let's unpack this circling Europe I
think her maybe let's even go a little
bit back to you know how did you even
get involved in all this where are you
from are you from Europe no from Austin
Texas from Austin Texas you seem like a
Texas guy I came in wearing boots yeah
and we tend to be real friendly it
started because I think I just love
questions that don't have good answers
yes me too yeah I think that's what
draws us together
yeah questions like why are we here of
course it seems like you love the future
and that question never has an answer
until we arrive so yeah that kind of
kept asking unanswerable questions that
it took me to
study religion in college and then to
this thing called integral theory and
it's this way of trying to make sense of
basically this basic assumption that
nobody is smart enough to be a hundred
percent wrong
nobody is smart enough to be 100 percent
wrong no be smart enough to be 100
percent right of course yes
okay but now nobody smart should be 100
percent wrong you have to be you have to
be pretty pretty amazing to like be that
dead wrong all the time so oh so it's
saying that at least you're right about
some something
okay so here's now there's the spectrum
of people that are right very rarely and
almost all the time something like that
exactly and so it's a way of kind of
reclaiming truth from this postmodern
like well everybody has a perspective
everyone but it's like okay no hold on
like yeah that doesn't make sense
because that's already privileged in the
perspective that everyone's perspective
is equal over the one that isn't yes so
a spectrum of relative truth kind of
gives us truth back while honoring the
or including that important
deconstruction that we've had yes in the
past couple hundred years that's a
really good way to put it is there's got
to be some sort of fundamental playing
field of truth first and then we can
build little buildings on top of this
playing field of truth yeah and then
slowly we add more and more little parts
of the playing field as we societally
agree gravity okay great we shouldn't
kill each other okay great what are
these other ones yeah yeah and it
there's a certain sense where I think as
a society we say like this is good
enough to move forward so like yeah
Newton's gravity was like incredibly
helpful and then we get like you know
relativity and general relativity and it
situates gravity and a larger frame
which is more accurate a little weirder
but but it's built off of that like this
is good enough for now so in the
integral parlance we'd say like
you transcend what came before but you
included and most people try to
transcend and exclude when they develop
and yeah it's just really unhealthy
transcendence include we'll have to that
circles to wealth inequality quite
closely um people that are right more
often are they going to look back and
say now it's time to include and educate
and bring other people up with me or
maybe not
what's that gonna look like so maybe
without wandering into that so I really
like that you do yeah they talk about it
eventually uh well I don't know that I I
don't actually have that much to say I'm
on wealth inequality I mean I think it's
problematic but there's something yeah
so I just I like applying that frame to
it just has me thinking and I can try to
think out loud but transcend and include
I really like that yeah yeah because
every time you transcending you just
keep to yourself your also your
happiness your actualization all these
things don't even come to good healthy
states of happiness and fruition you
actually end up in many cases just
feeling like you're by yourself and that
you own a boat now or whatever but who
are many friends and okay so this is
integral theory that's right and how did
you stumble upon integral theory it was
kind of a divine intervention in a way I
had my parents of a psychotherapist so
they they handed me a magazine that they
didn't even read but it was about can
big business it said like destroy and
that was crossed out and said save the
world and this was in 2004-2005 and I
had I had never heard of a triple bottom
line or anything like that it was and
but I it just never sat right with me I
mean businesses that is the power
structure that we we have for the the
way the world is and I just never seem
right that like business is
automatically evil or bad or
capitalism is bad and we can go into
that yeah just like yeah there's
obviously good and bad and there and
there's something it's giving us and and
overall like seems like the average
well-being of all beings is more or less
better the Pinker argument yeah exactly
yep so so then this this magazine was
about this integral theory basically
right as my dad gave me a CD set of this
philosopher Ken Wilber mmm right as a
professor invited me to like a
leadership training about a thing called
spiral dynamics which is another take on
the integral model or developmental
psychology that all came together in
Austin or was in Houston of all Houston
and actually I was at Rice University
and right at the same time I there was a
I was in the Religious Studies
department so there's a Buddhist monk or
there's a kind of a modern monastery in
Houston that one of my professors runs
and this monk offered a class on
meditation and I decided to go and
something just clicked I decided then
and there to commit to meditating for
the rest of my life yeah uh-huh
and I just yeah it's like I would be I'd
be drunk about to like take a test the
next morning and back you know I still
got to get my hour in like no matter
what oh you taught you're talking an
hour usually people are like oh yeah
five minutes you know that's usually
what I am five minutes an hour yeah
every day every day for 12 years and
then the work I do now is is kind of a
meditation so I've eased up I still do
some of the kind of like private my own
just sitting there and meditating but I
do this as a sim I don't actually put my
hands this way well actually there's a
very this is this is a prop that doesn't
get enough love on our on our set
actually but it is exactly that and it's
this this opening up handcrafted from
terracotta is the create in the form of
mudra
hand gestures of classical dance
throughout the Indian subcontinent jean
de muchacha the thumb touches the
forefinger
two palm up this gesture symbolizes
wisdom hmm and the open hand facing
upward gesture symbolizes hope may
wisdom guide you and hope sustain you
and so that's that's kind of one of the
one of the one of the beauties of of
other places in the world and I don't
have you met to connect guys yet no what
do they do
but connect and connect guys are super
cool they they're big things peace and
connective any human connectivity and
they do so by you know throw up your
right arm and then you just do this and
then you look at the other person's eyes
oh yeah and then you just go
and you just take that moment to feel it
and you slow down and then you vibed on
that
there's vibe so so that that's what
they're up to and they're doing that
across world they do it in circles as
well so circling Europe is also helping
individuals grow in group settings yeah
so now you this makes me think I'm
wondering like to like actively invite
the Watchers to like take a moment to
feel that connection like yeah how it is
to be with us watching it's easy to put
your podcast or your vodcast or whatever
in like listen to 2x like what
information am I gonna get yeah but then
there's this other way to listen where
it's like who are the the beings that
are talking and not just like what's our
connection like like how is our
connection impacting the viewer right
now correct
and our assumption of they're watching
like impacting how we're talking with
them yes yes and normally I usually
focus on the content of of course what
they're going to take away and also what
is happening right here right mesh those
two together but unpacking it to that
depth is is really good
I wanna if you have examples of things
that we want to do throughout that you
want to tie the audience in a more
intimate level we totally should because
we could have one even more intimate
there so you know so circularly in
Europe but prior to that you had all
these forces come at you and then you
started meditating an hour a day
meditations crucial mm-hm
I've done three 10-day meditation
retreats I'm trying to do more this year
and it's it's been life-changing I feel
much more quantum as' and in tune with
what's actually occurring here and how
did you go from all those forces coming
together to circling Europe do did you
end up going there and experiencing some
love from that group and then coming
back and starting it in the u.s. I did
yeah I went to an integral I mean my
road was
long and winding and included you know
playing in dive bars funk rock music and
all sorts of weird things but I ended up
at this integral conference and did the
practice of circling and it's just which
we haven't talked about yet but it just
made sense it was like oh now like this
is how I take my meditation into
conversation and then when I met the
European guys that we do a slightly
different version that maybe a more
European version of this practice of
circling and it just clicked I mean that
kind of connects where you're just
staring into each other's eyes yes when
I met my business partner Sean like we
just were just in so deep and just
talking about what was happening and
that we we just walked like to the
restaurant and what people were guiding
us because we were just like making eye
contact talking and walking sideways
yeah exactly but it just felt so good
and it was like meeting a like a soul
connection or something
yeah good that does kind of beautiful
connections around the world that we
want to foster more of yeah okay and so
what else happened and through this
conversation and so that the way I saw
they would they led these retreats but
then it was it was afterwards when they
weren't on that like my buddy Sean was
crying listening to a song missing his
girlfriend and the way that they were
with my roommates and like they were
they could see things about their
relationship there were seemed so so
obvious once they said them was so
hidden before and like so meaningful and
they could just bring out these loves
and these pains it's almost like an
artist right brightening or maybe even
better like a videographer doing color
correction so sometimes brightening
sometimes dampening and it just makes
the whole thing more beautiful and it it
just it was like oh yeah this I've read
about bringing a meditative presence
into everyday existence and I knew it
was possible and I'd thought of it but
now now I can live it and I can see
examples of like here's what it's like
when I'm arguing with my girlfriend
here's what it's like when I feel lonely
is that my family doesn't really want to
talk about what I want to talk about
yeah and it was it just felt so good to
be able to expand this awareness
I had cultivated over many years into
everything and so would you need to
unpack a little bit of conversation with
somebody before you can show them
something that might be hidden and then
you uncover it the veil
it depends I'm wondering if we can do it
now we never know yeah yeah yeah why
don't we yeah yeah why don't we let's do
it so with with us but yes yeah let's do
it
yeah let's see if we can do an example
right now and this would be an exercise
you would do encircling and definitely
encircling and then with some maybe
modifications at a bar or you know with
the toad ever totally wherever wherever
whenever yeah it's like meditation in
that sense exactly because you just like
meditation like no one needs to know
that you're becoming aware of what's
happening inside yeah exactly and we're
really just saying you can bring that
into conversation I was getting I was
getting very fuzzy when you were talking
earlier oh yeah oh I like warm inside it
was great yeah cuz I just feel really
good vibe so you know that's what really
helps the warm and the fuzzy happen and
thank you yeah so you bring it to
conversation that's exactly right yeah
so one of the ways would be like might
ask like are you are you still feeling
that warm and fuzzy I am but it was
really amplified when you were when you
were speaking because you know you were
you were teaching about it in a way that
everyone sits down in conversation and
every or even stands up or wherever we
are in conversation but rarely do we
have conversation with other people
where both people are just vibing and
fuzzy and loving and caring
yeah tell your smile like yeah you're
this glow too so okay so let's let's
unpack this so you're bringing circling
to conversation you want to do and let's
do a demo yeah and even in a little way
it's like right there when I I do it now
habitually no
your smile and then like it brings a
little bit more joy in me and then you
notice mine yeah and so it's kind of
like were this thing that's usually
unspoken and happening or noticing and
impacting us we're kind of like allowing
that to really be seen and the seeing
changes the Sears yeah yeah that's good
and then hopefully other people watching
the people in this case I think I think
the people watching have a good
understanding of the fuzzy of like that
warm fuzzy feeling so let's see
especially I guess this is probably a
pretty easy way you're walking down the
street you see somebody going you're
like okay that guy that man or woman is
really happy so I'm gonna smile and and
that changes that moment for you or
those couple moments yes oh and you
might risk to always depends on how much
you're willing to engage and and what
you what you want what you're inspired
to what you're called to but I've
noticed I now will often like speak to
that man who's smiling even it's very
simple whole yes I may be in a rush but
I just be like thank you thank you yeah
exactly
absolutely yeah and so then the overall
and them knowing that and getting that
feedback increases the smile so there's
this feedback literally totally but the
weird so it's awesome to talk about it
in the fuzzy warm side because I think
we actually as humans are just as
vulnerable going into the positive
feelings and showing those as into the
negative yeah yeah but I think you have
to increase your overall aperture to be
able to like you've been into the
richness of life so a lot of what we end
up doing and circling is is actually
welcoming darker more scary emotions and
so the same way like you know you felt
the fuzziness and we can kind of amplify
that by talking about it you know we can
also impact some dark and dark stuff
which is fun to unpack you're like it's
fun to unpack it's it can it can be a
lot to go public
with some of those fuzzy things you know
completely public but going to one
person or five people is way different
than going on a million-plus person
broadcast and being like here's all of
my closet right which eventually
hopefully everyone can do that
because then that would change the way
we all engage in a trusting and caring
way rather than a secretive blackmailing
greedy the kind of way yeah and we maybe
are jumping the gun but like part of
that kind of individual growth through
group consciousness or through
relationship is that the more you like
the way I see the world it's there's
kind of a everything is a mirror and
that goes both directions and so if you
see that that you're kind of always
projecting then you can you can actually
go either direction into yourself like
the more you can love and welcome and be
with and forgive these like crazy parts
of yourself that you're ashamed of or
don't think are okay yeah the more you
can actually do that for others and and
it's not that it gets like all kumbaya
because it's actually I think when you
can be with those emotions that you can
work with them skillfully so if I can be
with my anger I can I'm like okay this
is not an appropriate expression of it
so I'm not repressing it or whatever but
there is an appropriate expression where
I need to set a boundary and so then
when someone else is angry it's not that
I'm just like oh cool like I'll let you
be angry I mean it might be like no like
stop this is not okay and like I know
you're hurting who's to say what yes
I think that's a really good question I
would say the relationship is I'd say
tooth one the relative side of it is the
relationship so there's a certain level
of intimacy that I don't have with you
that means I'm probably gonna bring less
of myself forward yes but we both can
change that and then on the other side
there's kind of an absolute where if I
can if I can include my for me this is
my standard or my morals it's like if I
can include my heart in my expression of
anger like so I know like yeah yeah I'm
not I'm not making you an object of my
frustration but you're actually a human
being that I'm with as I'm like
expressing I think that's pretty much
always appropriate yeah that's good
bringing your heart to the conversation
to the anger with it
along with it yeah that's a good that's
a good question what who gets to
determine what's appropriate for anger
and I think the relationship between
those two people is a good indicator
well anger and you can't kill people
this is who says who that's we we've
been doing that since the beginning of
time we still continue to we're not
stopping it doesn't look like it's
stopping who's setting that who's
telling you you can't kill people the
Bible no more so the morals and
standards are rules that you come home
from work and your daughter's being
molested by your brother and you're
gonna you're gonna apply the rules of
standard and morality in that situation
yeah you you bring up a very good case
there's plenty there's plenty of cases
the guy walks up to you [ __ ]
home let let there's plenty of cases
there's there's the guy walking down the
alley with the gun and he approaches you
and he's about to blast your brains out
you want to kick the gun out of his hand
you want to run away you want to do
whatever possible and you kick the gun
out of his
and if you can get ahold of it you're
gonna know kick the gun out of his hand
and sprint away there's there's other
ways but there exactly it's not an
objective truth every single situation
it's dynamic it changes between people
but I'd be interested here what Jordan
has to say about the burro you come home
to the brother that's I wish I wish we
could the viewers can see your face so
krong's it's like this looks naively
personal to you know personal it's um
it's just understood just angers
understood violence's understood it's
been personal it's just easy its
even-keeled love 8 there's a thin line
between the two I think that's that's
really where my I'm like yeah we there's
some part of us it will always be like
that we have a reptilian brain stem that
we're never getting well that maybe we
are getting rid of I don't know about
the transhumanist kind of vision oh yeah
yeah but as far as the humans we are
today it seems like we're gonna like
violence is a part of us the I think we
have to find the and you bring up a good
point of like what is like the
healthiest expression what is a healthy
expression of violence yeah and I think
we kind of all there's a certain sense
in which there's something innate in us
when you can tell like beating up an
innocent person that doesn't that's not
good correct and like doing it in a way
where there's like referees and and
there's or even like a could be really
fine like MMA or something but but there
is a certain standard or there's a
certain like set of agreed-upon ways or
rules that we express this that seems
healthier and you'd be hard fine even if
somebody was trying to kind of take a
moral relativist of view you like you're
like really put them in in the ring so
to speak like I'd find it very difficult
like they would they would be basically
denying some part of themselves to try
to make the argument that there there
isn't innately a healthier and healthier
expression of these things yeah the the
most healthy expression seems to be the
one that is the least violent in all
situations I think
and that's just your opinion Alan you've
never you've never killed anybody
there's a there's a human element among
us did that brings them great joy kill
for no reason just to watch them die
there's a real interesting we we kind of
them jumping ahead of gangs we were
going to talk about developmental
psychology re I love it I want to weave
this in because so so there's a there's
two well basically we'll start with like
when we talk about development
it's basically an increase in complexity
or ability to make to choose things it
doesn't mean increasing goodness so this
one guy Lawrence Kohlberg studied
morality and came up with a scale that
was it was interesting it didn't matter
whether you said yes or no is it moral
or not it mattered the why you said it
so he identified like five different
levels of like okay you know you this
guy steals medicine for his wife is the
basic story sure is it moral or not and
this is good one there's more detail
that's a good one yeah so basically
there's a there's a yes it is and note
isn't for all five levels and it matters
not the what but more the why why yeah
but what's super interesting is that one
of his students as a woman Carol
Gilligan because then it can get impact
further and you could say that I stole
it to save her because she's the
breadwinner or I stole it to save her
because I would be lonely the rest of my
life and I burst is her health versus
focusing on her health right see on
yourself there's so many ways to unpack
that so the moral evolution goes from
like it's not a it's not about the the
is it moral or not it's about the why it
goes from like essentially like just for
my own goodness to like more like law
and order like well yeah he should steal
it but he should do the crime or pay the
price for crime to a more like Conti in
like what's good for everyone and you
might make the yes or no case for like
the categorical imperative but what's
really cool is it so this is like one
scale and then this woman basically on
on his scale like men were just like
more moral and this woman was like
[ __ ] can I say that yeah of course
swear as much as it [ __ ] one on this
program great so this woman was like
this is total [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] and then she was like oh
yeah basically men tend to see morality
in like rules and women she developed a
different scale of like increasing care
care feeling versus rules so her her
version was like it goes from like
selfish care to to like more like
in-group or like like ethnocentric care
yeah yeah to a more like universal care
correct to an integrated like worth it's
kind of masculine and feminine the rules
and the care uh-huh
so it so anyway going back to murder and
not killing the question is I think not
the interesting question to me is not
like is it right or wrong but why is it
right or wrong
yeah exactly so why and then why why
right because like we've all seen like I
don't know about you right and whenever
I watch like an end of the world movie
like 2012 or something and like the guy
is like risking the entire human
population for like his family yeah yeah
I'm like dude that's ridiculous yeah and
I know we can like take the archetypal
meaning behind it I'm like dude just
take take the hit yeah like it's not
it's not good for everyone yeah I I
would have to say that I would I really
want to say that I would sacrifice
myself for this for the first society
you gotta be willing to sacrifice
yourself for society I would - that's a
that's a big one but it's but when you
but that's why I don't understand why
why I don't understand why if you're
willing to do that you know if you're
willing to kill yourself for the
betterment of society why do you have a
hard time with you know using your
rationale to kill someone else
alright the diary okay here's here's an
example would you as technology
progresses and you have more and more
capability to rewire the way somebody
thinks and behaves if they make a
mistake and you can snap your fingers in
the
why what is the purpose of beating them
with the baseball bats and death if you
can snap your fingers and they change
and they'll never touch another child
again in their life well first of all
when you talk about beating someone with
a baseball bat still they're deaf you
know I'm not afraid I'm not afraid of
dying you think you got no I you know
you got your walking dead man but yeah
you just I mean people are being killed
Alan you know good people that are that
are doing what you're doing
Mitch trying to find a better way for
all of us and it's just threatening a
small number of people that will murder
just for that this small number of
people for policy on greed yeah yeah it
was I think one one thing that's really
dangerous I think is not contending with
these forces like yes that's one of
those I love watching The Walking Dead
it is a brutal show I I sometimes am
depressed after watching it but I'm like
I need I need to know that part of me
because it's there and I think it's in
everyone I don't think everyone has a
rapist and then per se but like there's
there's a there's a violence in us so
there's a part of us that will kill for
our families there will and it reminds
me I saw a guy wearing a shirt on an
airplane once it it was like a there was
a sniper rifle and it said if all else
fails vote from the rooftops yeah and
and I talked to him because I was like
man I want to know I was like what what
would you like vote for the from the
rooftops for and he's like my family and
I started this conversation that almost
no one engaged in because it's a really
difficult thing to ask but I think there
are things that we'd all vote for the
roof from the rooftops for and so it's
like what would you like you know if
because some that's what's obvious like
if it's like yeah you can vote from like
take your sniper rifle to take the guy
that's gonna like wipe out human
civilization like you would do it so so
it's like that that's for sure that's
one person to wipe out you
or the whole of course so it's like and
that's you pulling the trigger on that
person versus pulling the trigger on
yourself right yes but then then there's
this hole so that's the very extreme and
then there's there's some somewhere in
this in the spectrum it's like we all
land so it's like I think we have to
contend with these forces inside of us
I'd say like almost a hundred percent of
people would kill Swan person right to
save everybody I would say probably
closer to three out of every four people
would kill themselves for the planet no
you think it's really less you think I
think 75% of people would kill
themselves much less for society for
putting is less yeah sure holy [ __ ] but
but here's this very interesting
question you're naive now yeah you know
we're off the map but like but here is
great though I don't think it's because
of human nature surrendered leadership
this is surrendered leadership though
really overly you have to surrender
yourself to death to be a leader in this
case that we're painting definitely and
and metaphorically I think you have to
surrender yourself to death at every
moment to really really lead like it's
like you have to have your plan your
willingness this is what I want to do
and you have to be willing to set it
down if something better comes along or
if information comes along that changes
your view like god there's so many
things that I need to say right now
there's there's the one thing it which
is Peter teal saying that keeping your
company small and able to iterate quick
and not be logged down by government of
regulations and corporate structures and
all these things is really important
because one day you'll hear an idea and
you're like alright we gotta put that on
the back burner pivot do something else
make this impact in the world and the
other thing that came to mind was I was
another really good point that that you
made remembered exactly what it was
see any practice my memory but you you
said something else do you remember what
you said just before that
you can't talk like that as an
interviewer I was going in a different
direction basically I'm I guess I'm just
bringing he's I every moment yes that
was the thing
thank God I remembered I really wanted
to pull that one up dying every moment
is crucial I just posted about Richard
Branson saying this yeah but if you will
never never look back and regret you
just keep moving forward looking back
and regretting is the stupidest thing
you can do with your time it just it's
more fear it's more anxiety exactly oh
that's you after you murder that guy no
sense wallowing in regret sorry but your
dad's really important for this show
yeah grounded in the reality of murder
and it's just awful I you know I'm not a
that's awful and now as we've mentioned
I just assumed take my own life before
I'm gonna what you're pointing to is
like regret there's a there's almost a
dishonesty to regret because it and I
almost I would call like time traveling
like you you did the thing you did and
now you feel a different way because of
the thing you did not like if you you
would have acted differently if you
already knew it so you so you can't go
back and change what's done yeah so it's
like in it I think the dishonesty leads
to the fact that or leads to you not
learning yeah so I'm regretting instead
of coming in terms with yes like whoa I
made a mistake and I need to act
differently
yes and I think guilt does the same
thing guilt basically locks us in a
pattern of repetition like oh I did
something bad now I need to feel guilty
and punish myself and then I never have
to actually change because I know that
like I'll do my punishment and so it's
not that that we should not feel guilty
it's that like it's a guilt as a signal
like that's a door to open like there's
something I need to learn
exactly yeah yeah grew growing is
learning yeah yeah and the more that we
learn over time the more that we prosper
you actually said development was
complexity increases in complexity I
really like that and then you further
said that those increases in complexity
could be very manipulative greedy yeah
pieces in complexity
they could be prosperous ones that are
collective and individualistic in both
at the same time but it's that was
really interesting because there's
there's no correlation in the
developmental like Sciences until like
the highest level of development which
is like that took like point 1 1 percent
of the population there's zero
correlation between maturity of
development and happiness so just
because you get more moral or more
capable or more or have a like a wider
perspective from your of who you are and
what the world is doesn't mean you
actually are subjectively reporting
higher this is the whole happy happiness
is steeped in ignorance being be happy
steeped in ignorance you can be yeah
it's not necessarily correct or you can
also be happy or you can be unhappy
knowing how economies and banks and
political systems work yeah um so yeah
that's that's so where this development
of just a good way to think about it is
just the structure of your brain the
more and more that you learn the more
and more you have neurogenesis the more
stronger and stronger the connections
become the more and more you're able to
perceive the world in more nuanced and
complex ways and so that is that's
that's the development that's the
complexity and then from there is are
you learning good [ __ ] are you learning
dumb [ __ ] who's the who's who's to say
what is good and what is bad but but I
think that what you're teaching right
was circling as an example is good I
think that the things that we talked
about on the show are good I think that
not killing people is good I think that
providing people with air and water and
food is good you know maybe you got to
work a little bit harder to get
health care in life maybe maybe that's
important without those provisions
you're gonna create people that kill
kill people well and all these kind of
goods we could fair enough we could I
think we could go to one one way we
could is like hedge like I'm about to
and the other it's useful I think
sometimes to just say these are good
let's go with them and then and then if
we do that it's like I have a background
assumption I'm working with that like
this is most of the time or 99% of the
time and that there's there's always
outliers yeah this kind of situational
awareness or contextual awareness a
relational awareness that says like yeah
killing is not killing is good almost
all the time and we can really make
decisions based on this assumption and
as long as we're like open and and
adaptive will change our mind when the
time comes and we're being robbed do
that guys about to push the nuclear
trigger yeah yeah yeah see that's that's
good have a processing in the background
where I mean we need to take this I mean
we've been already over a half hour in
just broke the surface so this is
fascinating already and I can sense that
there are so many places to go with this
yeah okay so we started with this
integral theory and this idea of
developmental psychology and then we the
see increases in complexity and then we
talked about circling and we talked
about how people can feel different
vibes in these environments and grow in
group settings when they become very
vulnerable do you want to walk me
through walk us through an example of of
what is something you practice that
circling is yeah maybe on the deep
negative side or on the deep positive
side or like you know yeah okay can we
use you yeah use me yeah so wherever you
want we could take something simple like
when Ron said like oh you can't say that
you can't not know what to do
on a talk show exactly yeah how'd you
feel I felt like right away I was like
dude I need to make sure that I practice
my memory so that way as you said those
two things I need to log them visually
in my mind so I use another sense to
capture them and then I don't need to go
through that process so is there any
sense of like inadequacy or like shame
actually I just got so so you stew it
through I'm telling you it changed doing
sales changed my life for the better
selling [ __ ] to people changes your life
for the better because when you go door
to door to door to call to call to call
to business to business to business and
you get no - no - no - no - node it
changes your life you just you don't
care anymore when somebody says you
don't you don't feel fear or anxiety or
resentment or pain or disgust or any of
those negative things all you hear is
why did that person say no how can I be
better mmm that's all I starting to hear
now so you have a habit of like cool
like whatever that know is like I can
improve like I'm gonna learn from it
yeah and and it's just like a built-in
thing it's just gonna learn you know
it's [ __ ] built in twenty five and by
the time I'm 28 it's gonna be different
more advanced hopefully I can teach it
to other 18 and 16 year olds so that
they never have to go through the
anxiety and stress that that when
somebody tells them that because I
totally see what you're saying somebody
says that and you go moping because
you're like I'm not good enough right
yeah so what so what I'm doing right now
is I'm kind of like honing in I'm like
looking for almost like if you're
reading up you're like reading a
Wikipedia article of Alen like I'm like
where are the things I can click on to
go deeper yeah and and like so the
anodic see one like that was a that
wasn't basically there wasn't there
exactly it takes it shows me a new thing
from it and so I'm like and then now
what interest I'm like kind of
triangulating like between what you're
showing and then what I'm interested in
so like I'm I get really fascinated by
like oh you're like hopefully I can
teach this to 18 and 16 year olds yeah
so I'm like man you're like you're super
motivated to help people yes yeah yes
what's that motivation less because you
think about all of those things that I
just listed the fear anxiety stress how
did you like any of those things in your
life hmm no do you like your parents
dying from cancer or Alzheimer's No so
there are these certain things that you
just know are just these objective knows
and so if for at least for so many
people and so I gonna be 16 year old out
there that's like I want to experience
stress it's the most important thing for
you to understand pain and suffering so
that you can actually know what
happiness is there's all these
philosophical claims about that as well
but at the end of the day if I could
help young people care more about
feeling empowered and actualized at
younger ages and give them things like
integral theory at younger ages so they
can really start picking apart the way
the world works cybernetics integral
theory and cybernetics seem to go
hand-in-hand the way things work around
the world so I mean I going a little off
track here but just in general can you
imagine what it would be like to have
been 16 years old and to have had a 25
year old yeah bring you under their wing
and be like hey when these things happen
even though you're only starting to sell
don't let any of the times that people
say no to you ever hurt you along the
way and that way I wouldn't have gone to
hurt all those times along the way but I
would have still potentially retained
this really solid idea of what was right
so there am i okay so so first I'm like
one of the things we might do is like
you say I'm like yeah you like helping
people in like yeah normally that might
be like like an end of the conversation
but to me I'm like that's a door and I
don't actually know what that means for
you like my version of helping people is
different from yours correct so I use
that as a way to good go in and I ask
well what's it like yeah and then and
that's what I did and now we're we're
seeing what it's like for you and and
now I'm like I'm listening for what
you're saying and it's
me and like how I'm impacted but I'm
also listening for like the threads that
were weaving together so it's the
interesting thing about use it seems
like there's something where it's like
it's so obvious that you don't even
think about it like you're like what of
course 75% of people would kill
themselves for the fan of the world like
and it's almost a shock that Ron and I
are to have a different opinion and
you're like yeah like it hurt me and so
of course I want to help other people
like it's it's so much it's like so
ingrained in you that it's like the
water you're swimming in and you don't
even realize it's water it seems is that
right yeah the wood the way that you
paint it visually metaphorically makes
it so much more vividly real in my life
it's difficult to sit across people that
know how to recognize and unpack and
this is something that I've really been
discussing on the show is that the same
way that you identified me as a
Wikipedia page I identify you as a
Wikipedia page Ron as when every human
being is a Wikipedia page it's their
journey from the moment that they're
born where they're born what they did
when they were four where they were
raised who their family is how many
brothers sisters they had where they
went to school what do they do for
profession what impact do they want to
make in the world and this like
literally that was eight questions how
can you ever get stuck and not have a
question to ask somebody right that was
eight right there and that was just a
simple like that that life journey like
right there and then there's so many
more ways to unpack so something that
yeah go let's take those eight questions
and let's call that like a channel like
that's a dunno that's the channel of
like what what are you about or
something that's that's like often part
of circling and that's like amazing it's
great conversation and it brings us
closer
the thing that circling really does it's
unique is it offers another channel and
it's like it's basically like just
what's happening right here right now
let's talk about it so so the keys
questions like what's it like what's
happening in you was that that was the
Wikipedia one and this is the now yeah
the moment that you're in right
now what are you feeling right now right
and and it's like the Wikipedia thing
goes there's an infinity there right
yeah but there's another infinite in it
here more like no matter what's
happening there's a new infinity a new
infinity and so it's like yeah it's not
just like what are you feeling what's
you already feeling your body what are
you feeling in your emotions what are
you thinking but also like what's your
awareness like like right now you're
noticing things and and you can notice
that you're noticing yeah Metta yeah and
we're pretty and and and not just like a
kind of a metacognitive noticing but
like like we can kind of all do this
right now like probably just zoom
yourself out into the third perspective
looking down at the room something like
that yeah and then okay so you're doing
that right like you're you're noticing
that you're noticing like I have a weird
queasiness I'm surprised but yeah my
bladder is almost full yeah yeah there
you go
so you're noticing that and then you're
like oh I'm aware that I'm aware of that
and you do it you're looking at yourself
in the third person but let's look at at
from the first person of of the
awareness yeah so phenomenologically
like what what are you as the awareness
that notices your bladder is full and
what's that like yeah yeah well I'm
totally whenever I go in a third person
I always envision ants because if you're
looking at the Earth from Saturn it just
looks like a pebble that I just have
seven and a half billion ants on it and
that's what the humans are and okay so
stay with that vision okay because I
wanted to go back to yours but okay then
right and then you're noticing that like
what what's the you that is aware of
that
what's the me that is aware of that yeah
yeah well the whole diet that leads us
to the question of what is I what am i
Who am I yeah that that's the meditative
question when I completely lose your ego
whether you take psychedelics you
meditate all the way there yeah so one
of the circling injunctions would be
like you don't have to answer that
question right but now you're in it
we're kind of maybe dipping in and out
of it maybe the listeners or Watchers
are in it in and out of it too so I'm
I'm now like letting myself be that
awareness and and my jordan care
is arising inside of that that awareness
and it's all the Jordan things like I'm
Jordan in this moment like I'm making
sure ever likes me that I'm doing good
things blah blah and I'm watching that
now can i express like including the
Jordan can i express as that awareness
so I'm like infinity or I'm emptiness or
I'm spaciousness that's now like
inhabiting form and speaking to another
infinity ASIS open okay yeah and that's
just what conversation is yeah most
people don't think about it to that
extent you're basically thinking about
it for your 31 years of life you're put
that into right this moment all that all
the forces that have come into you and
then what are you saying
in the perceived environment that you're
into the other thing that has been
around for 25 years of time and through
all their things that they've been
through but then there's so much more
this is yeah okay and now am i excited
about this infinity concept because I've
been reading about like math and and
number theory set theory and like a and
infinities and I'm like man it is like
there's two infinities meeting yes even
if I like die evil don't know how to
access the infinities right that's the
big thing
that's what circling gives you exactly
and that's what the meditation gives you
that's what psychedelics give you that's
what questions give you really questions
can be your substitute for so many
things in life even if you don't want to
do we always say this on the show if you
don't want to practice inner management
or we always tell people practice in or
management but if you don't want to
practice inner management just learn how
to ask really good questions and that by
itself will take you to a whole new part
of life and so and these these sorts of
practices get us to a point of like
oh yeah and if I would like just to like
give a concrete thing to add to that
like when you're
asking good questions like to someone
else like like you can add in the
assumption that you don't know what
they're talking about even when you
think you know and that's gonna lead to
really cool questions yeah it'll lead to
you listening yeah as well yeah I like
the mathematical notion of infinities
super fascinating was a Zeno's paradox
where you're walking to the wall 1/2 1/2
1/2 yeah the continuum can never get
there yeah and then there's uh then
there's even what we just said your
Wikipedia page is infinity and then this
moment is infinity but when one needs to
know how to access the Wikipedia page
one needs to know how to access the
moment and do it in a vulnerable way in
a way that builds trust yeah yeah all
that good stuff yeah because a big
mistake that we see people do in when
they first get into circling it's like
they get so excited about the the
Wikipedia page or the moments infinity
that they kind of like forget that a
relationship always has two parts so if
I'm just focused on you the relationship
isn't that exciting or it's ours pretty
quick exactly oh my gosh you're speaking
the volume so here's here's something
interesting
ok let's say that your statistics are
50% of people in the world would not
kill themselves for of the other 7 and a
half billion people I would go ahead and
argue that those are the 50% of people
that you could just go and infinity be
rattling off questions to them and they
would never ask you a question back that
would be a some sort of an argument that
could potentially exist in the world it
gives me a feeling of sadness like they
they're the ones that suffer the most
from that
yeah we were just so loud and you
brought us to such a quiet place I
really appreciate that hmm Thanks I like
being able to go from the loud and
really cognizing to the quiet and
feeling I appreciate that you did that
what is it about that that can be fixed
that is what circling does that is what
meditation does psychedelics whatever
these questions it fixes the I would
sacrifice myself for seven and a half
billion people it fixes the these the
the inability to ask somebody really
good questions that leaves them down at
the moment cuz do you gave a really good
example earlier you were dissecting me
and I like that because it shows that
I'm serious
it's very very very very hard to find
people that know how to dissect well
it's just difficult and I'm very
grateful that you showed that example of
dissecting because a lot of what we do
on the show is we dissect we ask people
really good questions and we help them
speak from their heart and their brain
yeah the whole body system can speak and
and that's it's an interesting it's
interesting thing because even
dissecting like it it is true but I
would be careful with the metaphor
because that they create a reality it's
like the way we frame that yeah the
understanding does create something and
like we can only really dissect
something by killing it do you think so
why can't we just act the way normally
the language doesn't doesn't mean
doesn't mean like you've got like a dead
pig in science class and we'll cut it
open yeah but I think dissect doesn't
not necessarily mean needs to be injured
or killed to open up in that sense I
think dissect can be metaphorically open
up your brain and heart to the
conversation that is a
yeah I'm out of it without physically
doing it yet yeah so because for me it's
like it's a process of actually getting
more intimate with you yeah and and with
myself
yes like yeah I'm I'm noticing what I'm
curious about I'm noticing how similar I
am to you and I'm like likewise it
touched by like seeing how how like my
care is often unseen by me like it just
is it's a thing that motivates me and
I'm like oh yeah like it's actually a
cool thing to notice and appreciate
about myself that I love through
appreciating and noticing you yeah
exactly exactly and these types of
circles of recognition to to further to
the to the conversation going into
places that is very enriching for both
parties cuz they both know how to engage
each other and then recognize and engage
and recognize that seems to be a lot of
what happens at circling and I don't
even know it I mean I read a couple
documents listened to a podcast on it
and now all of a sudden I'm like I was
literally about to tell you a minute ago
I was like I want to teach I wanted to
be within the San Francisco Bay Area
curriculum of teaching for circling
awesome or sure for sure I do I want to
participate and then I want to teach and
there's you know I would teach different
things you you can probably tell that if
I don't know how okay it is for circling
to be teaching different things but my
my you know my practice is a little bit
different you know that whole thing that
we were talking about with sails and not
just caring learning how to stop caring
about the anxiety and the fear and that
kind of stuff you know maybe that's one
of the things and maybe another one of
the things is the is the is the whole
understanding that you are a Wikipedia
page I am a Wikipedia page you can have
infinite questions about each other's
Wikipedia pages and now it's like what
are the eight basic questions for the
Wikipedia page where were you born how
many brothers and sisters and family
members do you have would you go to
school what did you go to school for
where do you work what do you care about
making in the world right so these basic
asked questions that can be
your infinite Wikipedia questions that
we never run out of questions in your
conversation with people and then maybe
another one of the infinities is helping
people understand you guys are probably
even better than I am at it even though
I've meditated and done some of these
activities before and psychedelics and
everything you guys have been practicing
unpacking the moment
yeah and unpacking the truth in those
moments and the questions that can come
up in the feelings and the and the
vulnerabilities and and that's something
really beautiful that I would love to
come and learn about further the
question that eight questions makes me
think of a slightly different tack I
think we take and and there would be
room like if you come in like every it's
the one of the cool things about
circling it's kind of like an
evolutionary methodology so it's it's
constantly including new people and new
fits the process itself evolves to
include to transcend and include like to
take what was there before and grow cool
but it's with the questions I think
there's a sense of what you do have to
like teach people to fish I'm sorry you
do have to give people fish to teach
them to fish so there's certain so yes I
wouldn't ever take away those those
eight questions but then I'd say like
like that's only a way to start to learn
to eventually like I don't do the lively
juicy awesome conversations are not
going to come from you like looking down
you're like kind of spreadsheet of
questions half core it's gonna be from
you like finding the thing that's most
interesting to you and having developed
the confidence to step into the
vulnerability of like risking that
exactly yes because the really deep
questions like are almost always scary
to ask and it doesn't mean it's like you
know oh like it's not and it's not a
question like you know like well do you
know what are you kind of sex do you
like or something like that like that's
that's a pretty good question I like
that yeah good we could go there
[ __ ] asking people what impact do you
want to make in the world we're just
gonna walk up to them be like what kind
of sex do you like yeah hell yeah so
that one actually might be interesting
and you might find it but but probably
the one that's going
take us deeper and juicier it's like is
like do you like me or like how is it to
be with me or or yeah what kind of sex
do you like probably you're asking
someone a woman or a man and you really
want to know is like do you want to have
sex with me and like it's like like
we're even like I don't want to have sex
with you right now but I'm interested in
what kind of sex do you like but then
there's so much more to unpack from
where you're just saying yeah really
really enjoyed how you're like it's not
some sort of regimented outline it's
just a you know you're supposed to
practice risking yourself to get into
the moment to be vulnerable to get into
that scene and then once you do that
over and over again it just becomes a
natural rhythm of that and learning your
your limits as well so it's not like
always you should go be more vulnerable
like there's a certain sense of you know
like I can risk this much because I can
handle the rejection and for you as
sales like you can handle so like almost
an infinite amount because you're gonna
grow no matter what so like you can risk
a lot but with someone else I would
really discourage them from that I'd say
very true start with some small thing
Airy so you can yes you can really kind
of and stay close to yourself like like
one let go ask something you know that
it's vulnerable but it's small and then
when if you get a rejection like see if
you can open to that yeah yeah instead
of like going off to like another
thought or a way to fix it or a new
strategy or what are on to Facebook or
from Netflix like just for a second like
yeah like what's actually happening in
your being because that's where the real
growing is gonna come it's like a
full-bodied growing you know like oh
yeah I can oh what's happening is that
I'm afraid that like I'll be like on a
primal level like kicked out of the
tribe and like I know that's not true
because this is a total stranger at a
bar or something but like but I can stay
with that feeling and actually that I
know it's not true while feeling it is
where the like change occurs I mean this
like dual awareness of like of like this
is silly and it's okay like
exactly that's it and it's silly it's
okay and you want to learn from it no
matter what the outcome is towards you I
we can unpack so much more about this
and I'm really what would be a really
important takeaway to give people that
are wanting to get involved in
surrendered leaders you just described
one but taking that extra moment those
extra bits of time to process what's
actually going on yeah absolutely there
is a sense in which going you can go
slower to go faster mmm
so a lot of times we spent in it this is
like so I do get to work with businesses
sometimes they can't count them in a
wrote that book think you fastest though
really good book oh yeah yeah about the
tortoise and hare and no well then
there's the system one thing a system -
yeah yeah yeah system - who's gonna bias
you all the time towards the quickies
right and then the system 1 thinking is
like to slow down like you have no idea
what 12 times 72 is right now but then
if you actually slowed down 720 plus 144
yeah exactly exactly yeah yeah go ahead
go ahead
so so one this is a very complex weird
take away but I'm just going there go
ahead one of the things like people come
often because they're into meditation or
personal growth and and there's a sense
in which that is there's a very healthy
development of the self as an individual
as an agent with more and more autonomy
kind of differentiating away from our
like so we should be this way Society
says this and we get more and more
freedom as an individual right that's
healthy and I like it and what we do is
like as hopefully a transcendent include
of that because there's a certain limit
to that to what that autonomy can
accomplish on its own and there's a
there's I think an interdependence
or like that sometimes what we call
surrender and it's like it's being
willing to step into the not knowing and
the unknown that's that's really gonna
guide us in the especially with these
huge questions like these existential
risk questions about whatever ai and by
orphen biowarfare yeah all these kinds
of things it's like we we don't have
answers yet we can't there's so there's
a sense in which like one of our deepest
limitations is the assumption that we
can know so it's like suspending for a
moment that like I'm ever gonna get it
right or that I'm ever gonna be enough
or that I'm gonna have all the answers
and like once I let that go for a second
that my rational mind will know and I
open to other inputs like I'll start
noticing a lot of stuff that I hadn't
noticed before
I'll start noticing like my body
sensations which there's massive body
intelligence
yes it's honed over the basically the
course of our history as humans so like
our analytical reform elaboration or
cognition is pretty young in this scale
of our species so it's like this it's
super important I think it's like the
most complex thing that like biological
life has produced to date that we know
of but it's constantly buzzing in that
domain rather than this inner management
domain
yeah and ideally we can harness that
that cognitive capacity to include more
so it's top-down and bottom-up it's it's
the body intelligence it's the heart
intelligence it's the intuition but it's
also like you're nodding like the fact
that you're nodding at me is telling me
like oh yeah you like what's happening
and then you know your foot's life I
really liked you I yeah well then I'm
also in there's little things from like
your foot slightly going like this and
oh my god bet there's something you're
like waiting to say or like I don't know
yet maybe if it's my ankle maybe you've
got a tick or maybe I don't know but but
like once I start knowing and paying
attention anymore and I risk like well
what is your what's happening that
[Music]
I'll start like getting more cues like
I'll know when to use that more and when
not to I'm gonna feel your heartbeat
yeah so I would encourage people in in
there leading like to it's it's never to
throw away that autonomy or that plan or
that leading it's that's so important
but to like situate that in a larger
context like and especially probably the
people are watching this are really
interested they're probably drawn to
like even how much you love to help
people and you want to like in suffering
or reduce suffering so it's like when
you think about the scale of suffering
on the planet and the scale the problems
that we're facing like you we just can't
solve them alone when it comes to like
greenhouse gas emissions even even like
the Western nations can't solve the
problem they say it's a global issue
that requires like in an an incredible
amount of interdependence an incredible
amount of relating and reliance on each
other and agreements and and like I
don't even know if there's a game theory
and a in a computational system complex
enough to like make the calculations for
that maybe there is or maybe there will
be with photon computing or something
but like but like given that it's like
it's like okay cool like we want to
tackle these massive issues and and
we're going to keep growing but like
let's also open to like listen to more
than we know and let's slow down and be
willing to like to receive stuff that
doesn't make sense at first it doesn't
fit in our framework there's actually
those are the things that are gonna be
most helpful good yes yes okay how about
we ask you what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
a flower in bloom and and then that
metaphor of like watching somebody
realize something for the first time or
like find a unique expression of their
being I see it as a blooming flower like
yeah they're they become aware of a new
of a new possibility that they'd never
known before and it's just like utter
joy and freedom I kind of felt a little
bit that way
a couple times sometimes this
conversation sometimes I felt like a
blot of bloom sometimes a little less
bloom but in my mind was definitely
expanded into great new areas of thought
okay actually I think it's especially
important to as we have all these
existential conversations to realize
that it's gonna take the whole tribe of
Earth to figure out a lot of the
existential conversations and it's
always both like the part of the idea of
the surrender and leadership is like
it's a it's embracing two poles you know
the the chaos and the order for the
Jordan Peterson fans like the masculine
and the feminine the structure and the
openness and so there's the knowing and
the not knowing
so even we're like talking about yeah
look it takes the whole tribe it also
takes an individual there's another
polarity of like it's not just inclusion
like the inclusion has I think I think
to deal with the complexity we're in it
has to include a willingness to make
hard calls to make divisions to say this
is better than that this and even like
on the whole like this tribe is better
than that tribe at this or like we need
the even if it's if it seems this is I'm
about to say something I think it would
be too politically incorrect but if I'm
like I'm just gonna do it because I
think I can say it in a way that conveys
the meaning and I won't do it if I'm
like the like the jerk like overall the
Germans are better at like making
the steel that we need for this thing
like we and it's a it's a world ending
thing or like we need to embrace that
and recognize that and say that that's
okay to make that distinction why were
you nervous about that being politically
incorrect you know the Germans excel at
engineering we need to acknowledge that
they also take pride in their homeland
and keep it very clean there's there's
lots of positive aspects about all the
cultures are less planet than if we all
recognized you know that we we're all in
this together you know we need each
other and that's the lesson in it and
nobody we just haven't got that
understand exactly I think it's because
I'm afraid like what I'm really willing
to say is that we need each other and to
do that like we need to be willing to
make valued distinctions exactly yeah
yeah I think that's an unpopular view
because nobody wants to admit that
they're - inferior to another mind and
that works both individual individually
but also tribally and then especially
nationally so the more that we do admit
that the better I just want to like I
just want to say that there every single
human on earth is better at being
themselves than I am at being bad yeah
so there's that I love absolutely and
then there's there's probably even
aspects of their Wikipedia pages of
their life journeys that are obviously
unique to them that they know to be
SuperDuper objectively true like what
you were raised in a certain country of
the world and these certain things were
happening there I don't [ __ ] know
that I would have had to watch three
documentaries read three books on topic
to even visualize what it would be like
so okay how about how about do you think
we're alone in the cosmos I think not do
you think there's an advanced
civilization roaming the cosmos
I think probably it's just so big it is
and I know that's what he said because
it's true because the woman can also
become very large you know down in her
jaw there's and there's something I
don't know all right yeah I know they're
like there's the Fermi paradox and these
things but I'm not in it and I know
there's like all the like this is like
there's the limit of the speed of light
but I'm just like man it is too big and
honestly I think it's too arrogant to
think that were the only ones or even
the first I know somebody had to be the
first but do you think they live among
us no I don't maybe in like a spiritual
sense maybe I don't know maybe there's
some maybe in a way that we don't
understand yeah yeah exactly and then do
you think we're at a computer simulation
do you think this is base reality I
think this is base reality why
if you really take yourself into that
view from Saturn well it's it's a tricky
it's tricky because although I say that
I think I do hold like this as an
illusion so it's kind of a flip like I'm
like from the scientific point of view
I'm like I'm like yeah I think this is
not a simulation but I do think that
like from a spiritual perspective like
you can see let's not even go spiritual
like there's an emptiness like right now
when I look at you I think of you like
as a being as a thing like it's a whole
thing but like it's actually just a way
that I'm framing reality through
language yeah and through like false
boundaries because you're actually
millions of like bacteria and and you're
ace if i zoom in you're like all these
intricate like interrelated systems and
all this shoulder hair yeah you got like
more shoulder hair than my drummer used
to have so I mean like whoa and and and
yeah it's like so there's something
that's like inaccurate and and and about
saying that you're even a person because
like we're not when I think about Who I
am
like I think as if I had a trajectory
because I did but like really like I'm
not any of the nothing that I ever was I
am like that's included but like I am
something new right now that I've never
been before and I don't actually know
what I am moment-to-moment
yeah and I'm only knowing myself in
saying this and in being seen and heard
by y'all so there's something like
really trippy about that and so in that
sense like even myself hood like even
the thing I take to be primary is
illusory yeah exactly the consciousness
is illusory in that sense yeah yeah yeah
but but it's like but you are bounded
you are bounded by the flesh vehicle but
you also are not right yeah that's
that's this paradoxical beauty and
mystery in and so there's a pragmatic or
like a utilitarian point of view or
something which which says like if I
hold this as a simulation I guess a
dream that I can wake up from
and I learned like to like the
techniques of waking up like in this
case like some sort of meditation or
then like what ends up happening is like
it it gives me a freedom that allows me
to even if I'm wrong like inhabit this
world with more joy and more beauty and
more appreciation and more acceptance
and more flow and yeah and more
generosity and more kindness and more
passion yes and that's like seems like
universally agreed upon to be like yeah
let's go for that exactly
Wow I so grateful for this conversation
this is part one if it's gonna have to
be a couple parts I'm gonna have to go
do some some some surrendered leadership
myself a little bit of circling myself
I'm gonna have to go do some of that in
San Francisco hopefully maybe teach a
little bit about these infinities of
these Wikipedia pages of this moment of
infinity would would you sacrifice
yourself for the seven and a half
billion people on earth it's a very
interesting question and I'm glad we
broke that ground today and we'll be
breaking much more ground in the future
guys if you had a good time what's the
like give us a comment give us a
subscribe you know hook it up man hook
you up yeah get it get it yeah we'll
have all the link to circling Europe
calm just for fun yes why what's the
good that comes out of them liking and
subscribing yeah so the essence of it in
general is that we want more people
watching this content because you know
what you just described in this
conversation and you know the value that
it has for more people to hear it yeah
and the more people that do like and
subscribe and share with other people
the further that content can get
disseminated across the planet
implemented into life it was kind of
like if if somebody watching this really
enjoys what's happening that like they
can probably feel that others might like
it too
exactly and and then it's even better
when you take the actual link and
and that directly to the individual
people and be like totally worth your
time right that is really because you
know going and sharing it across
platforms is fantastic going in
individually messaging it to people that
you know specifically would really
benefit from it is also fantastic and
then furthermore as we need to sustain
this and you guys know this
we have patreon we have a patronage
people that follow us and support us
there they get exclusive benefits they
get to support us here in our studio
helping make our guests comfortable
helping us with all this equipment and
all the beautiful content that we're
producing here for you guys so join us
there patreon.com for simulation series
Jordan thank you so much you so much an
absolute pleasure me too I'm really
excited to continue the conversation of
the future thank you Ron Vargas are
producing partner thank you so much
great conversation and we'll catch you
guys more tomorrow thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you